100 millions c'est le nombre de doses de
vaccins que cuba souhaite produire en
le directeur général de l'institut fine
les du vaccin à la havane pilote deux
des quatre projets de vaccins parmi
lesquels soberanes à 2 le candidat
vaccin le plus avancé à ce stade nous
prévoyons certainement de produire
jusqu'à 100 millions de doses de
soberanes à deux c'est le vaccin le plus
avancé actuellement si tout se passe
bien pour nous cette année nous faisons
vacciner toute la population cubaine des
touristes auront également la
possibilité s'ils le souhaitent de se
faire vacciner à cuba ces cours d'eau
mais les autorités n'ont déclaré aucun
effet négatif sur les premiers tests la
phase 2b a donc débuté ce lundi
quelques 900 volontaires ont passé les
essais cliniques
si cette phase est réussie la troisième
pourra débuter et impliquera cent
cinquante mille volontaires en mars
prochain
la dernière étape avant approbation du
vaccin l'objectif étant de débuter la
campagne au premier semestre 2021 outre
soberanes à deux trois autres candidats
sont en préparation à des stades moins
avancés soberanes à 1 contre les
variantes du virus ainsi que abdallah
aimant by sa si cuba fait partie des
pays les moins touchés par la pandémie
avec un peu plus de 19000 cas il n'en
reste pas moins impliqué dans sa lutte
un vaccin gratuit et non obligatoire qui
va également être testé sur la
population iranienne
grâce à l'accord signé entre l'institut
pasteur d'iran et cuba le 7 janvier
dernier sur l'île où un quart du budget
est consacré à la santé
ce vaccin est perçu comme une lueur
d'espoir
le pays connaît malgré tout un léger
rebond épidémique là où l'embargo
américain pèse depuis 1962 cuba dû
développer ses propres vaccins depuis
plus de trente ans puis de 80% des
vaccins du programme national
d'immunisation sont produits par des
laboratoires cubain d'où la volonté de
commercialiser leurs propres vaccins
la stratégie de cuba pour commercialiser
le vaccin est une combinaison qui dans
un premier temps se concentre sur
l'humain et l'impact sur la santé et
dans un deuxième temps s'intéresse à la
nécessité pour notre entreprise de
maintenir la production du vaccin et des
médicaments pour le pays sauvé rana 2
serait alors le premier vaccin anti
qu'ovide d'amérique latine
un avantage non négligeable pour le sous
continent qui ne dépendrait pas des
laboratoires internationaux
autre atout selon les autorités
sanitaires le vaccin ne nécessiterait
pas de conditions particulières de
réfrigération